okay you land what's the refugee camp in
Germany like I mean listen man it's not
what you think it's just a bunch of
people that are trying to fight for
Freedom you know we're all from Poland
from Czechoslovakia at the time
Yugoslavia family you know Anna Maria
you know the staff family over here and
we're all living together every that
would come they would drop off the food
you would go pick it up the Apple you
know juice all this stuff milk you would
bring it in we had a small little park
it was an Army base right next to us and
so we would go and look over the
building to see what the guys were
blowing up in the army base so
um
that's what it was like and you know
you'd go to school and they would look
at you you know you came to our country
and you're making it worse because there
was some you know a lot of things were
going on with the stabbing the fights
all this stuff so I'm a middle eastern
guy you automatically put that person
into you you can't blame the guys to be
thinking that because there was a lot of
that going on in Germany but it was it
was a uh it was a different experience
how did you get to America
uh so we're there for about a year and a
half eventually we get the green card
and uh we get the call we're going and
it's November 28 1990. we land in New
York
uh I'm looking for uh Rocky I'm looking
for ragoonies I'm looking for Gremlins
if you remember Gremlins back in the
days where are these guys at I couldn't
find any of them eventually we got 12.
there's some gremlers out here
and then eventually we get to LA from
New York and you know now any idea why
La sorry well I mean yeah pay respect to
Mecca right which is Glendale
Granada Hills then Glendale and then we
stayed in Glendale for six years oh wow
so everybody looks like this in Glendale
your parents plan the whole time was to
go to Glendale no no no not at all my my
dad wanted to stay but my dad also had a
sister in Chicago so he would always
come back and forth from Chicago in 84
he comes back he brings this tape with
the best 80s songs so when we came in
you're playing the 80s music it was sick
because every time I listened to 80s
I'll go back to that tape by the way
whoever picked the songs I'm still
trying to figure this out Calvin Harris
you know all this stuff we played it was
great
um but yeah you know it it's uh it was a
great experience okay growing up in L.A
you feel probably a little bit more
comfortable I imagine because you're
growing up around a lot of people kind
of look like you shared experience I
think at this time there's a lot of
persons that are moving into Beverly
Hills they also left out for the shop
though right so there's so now maybe you
don't feel as uh out of place
is that fair to say I felt at a place in
Germany I didn't feel out of place in no
I'm saying and absolutely you're right
okay you're in place in Glendale yes
yeah absolutely the desire to be
American right to prove your
american-ness
does that happen when you're a kid
moving here you're seeing the movies and
you're like I want to take part in this
experiment does it happen when you're in
L.A
I'm wondering because you go to the Air
Force and I've always thought that like
that is a way of proving that you're
willing to pay the price to be part of
this Amazing Experiment was that your
motivation so you know the the concept
the evolution of becoming a proud
American probably happened due to a few
different events one of them I would say
is as you age whatever your parents sold
you whatever your teacher sold you
whatever the pastors Uncle sold you then
you find the contradictions and the
arguments and you're like yeah I don't
know about that because in Iran you've
grown up in an environment where
everybody says mad bad um recall mad bad
on because death upon America and
they're flagellating their back and
you're like looking outside hearing
these ten thousand men screaming like
why death upon America it's the evil
empire it's horrible let me tell you
what they do they're rewarding they're
behind all the wars and they do this and
they're like okay maybe they're right
maybe they're not I don't know yet
skeptical let me find out for myself
rich people are greedy and all this
other stuff and I'll go wait a minute
what are you talking about the only way
you become rich is to help other people
around you also become rich you can
become rich by yourself most people that
build a company that grew up they don't
have 100 equity in the company you have
to share the equity other people come in
you have to have jobs you have to
recruit good people you have to keep
them you're about to lose the guy you
don't give them that race he's going to
go elsewhere you can't become rich by
yourself you're going to need other
people that's going to help you out so
contradictions then I join a military
I'm in the Army Hunter first Airborne
Division it's September of 97. we walk
in the unit they say there's a movie
coming out it's about our units
as long as we can get it we watch a
movie I'm all in I love movies so we go
600 kids when I say kids 18 to 25. this
movie you're going to be the first to
see it before it's public because it's
about your unit you have to be proud
about this movie it's your unit it's the
badge it's I'm like okay great let's see
what this is
Saving Private Ryan no let me tell y'all
do the movie ends we're all on fire
I'm so fired up about this movie that
I'm coming out saying you know what I'm
proud to be an American then we go to
one of the military ceremonies whether
it was Memorial day or fourth of July
and I'm looking at these 40 year old
generals toughest man in tears coming
down and have a look like this but
they're crying because they lost the
soldier and you know how they fought for
freedom and everybody was kicking it
hanging out they're not thinking about
the people that had the hard lives and
I'm interviewing these guys what was it
like what was he like who's your friend
who's this and he gradually like listen
man this is this is an incredible
country and then more and more and more
as you come up in a regular guy like
this
with a 4.6 GPA
1510 s.a.t
you know all of a sudden you're like uh
man you can actually win here and then
gradually the levels to winning keeps
going you're like you know what else is
possible here it's just like playing a
game I'm gonna play this game out and
see where it goes and then obviously
I can sell this is the greatest country
in the world comfortably
in many different ways results Freedom
you know what we've been able to produce
why so many people come here if we're a
restaurant it's a restaurant that's
always full everybody's in line trying
to get into this restaurant even when
we're busy even more people want to come
here legally illegally risk their lives
it doesn't matter everybody wants to
come here so now that doesn't guarantee
this place is going to stay this great
you know I'm having breakfast with a a a
very successful man in Hollywood and
we're going back and forth and the
question that becomes okay so now what
do we do I got four kids yeah I got 11
year old nine-year-old six-year-old
she's going to be seven tomorrow
and I got a two-year-old she'll be two
in a month
we have a great life but man can you
imagine it's kind of like well I made my
money I'm just gonna chill I'm not going
to put myself out there because I'm just
kind of want to be invited to all these
parties I don't want to be not invited
to these parties I don't want to be not
part of these networks no we got to do
our part as well so I feel there's a
responsibility now to uh to bring it
from a different angle you know I'm
Middle Eastern so I can talk to white
black Hispanic Middle Eastern Asian
Christian atheists Rich poor middle
upper educated uneducated let's talk
let's hash it out let's see how many
things we have in common and what things
we disagree with give me your argument
why give me your argument why now let's
see what we got there so I think that's
that's kind of the concept of what
happened with the love for America I
wanted to ask you a question when you're
growing up you come here what's your
mentality about how you're going to take
advantage of being in America are you
looking at it like I'm going to start my
own business capitalism at my fingertips
no I came here not trusting America came
here like looking at the white man like
I've learned a lot about you Mr white
man I see you coming to school in the
BMW and we're coming in and they used 79
Honda Accord hatchback you know that
only goes Drive doesn't go reverse okay
you're special you think you're better
than me right so that that bit of
animosity or kind of looking at them uh
funny that was there there was nothing
about I'm gonna come here to become rich
and do this no of course don't get me
wrong I was the dreamer since I was a
kid uh Wilson Junior High School were
coming down Verdugo I beat a guy say
we're all walking down and I said listen
guys question for you okay you got one
of four choices which one do you want to
be you can be the richest man in America
Bill Gates you can be the best athlete
in America Michael Jordan you can be the
best performer in the world Michael
Jackson or you can be the president who
do you want to be and we debated for 30
minutes it was great at that time it
would probably be uh money because I
grew poor you know I I didn't have a lot
of money so it was more that and now if
I could jump 48 inches that listen are
you kidding me I mean it's not even a
question about it same answer right now
you'd be the athlete if you could jump
48 inches it's not just an athlete
you're gonna get the billion because
you're Michael Jordan it's Michael yeah
I just want to make sure you were saying
no man it's Michael you know it's it's
Michael I would never want to be Bill
Gates yeah ever I have zero interest in
being Bill Gates most of those answers
sounded unappealing which one uh Michael
Jackson God nobody wants to be that uh
Bill Gates Jesus Christ
why Jackson
I mean out of gates and president
president
so that's kind of what the angle you're
growing yeah I feel like if you're
Michael and you have aspirations to do
the other two you can
you'll see why
foreign